maxine waters big mouth may have gotten
derrick chauvin off the hook in the
trial regarding the death of george
floyd
my phone gives me alerts on things that
just happened
i mean you can't avoid it and it is so
pervasive that it is i just don't know
how this jury
it can really be said to be that they
are free from the taint of this
um and now that we have us
representatives uh
threatening acts of of
violence in relation to the specific
case
it's it's mind-boggling to me well i'll
give you the congresswoman waters may
have given you
something on appeal that may result in
this whole trial being overturned but
what's the state's position
as well it should as well it should we
we played what
maxine waters said yesterday was very
clear it was a call to riot
and so this new information that could
affect the trial of derek chovin for the
death of george floyd
the new information isn't about anything
that happened on the day and the drugs
in the neck and the
police officers no it's going to be a
political consideration
because you have elected democrats in
this country
who are calling for riots trying to
interfere in our justice system
maxine waters is a greater threat to
justice
and peace in this country than the worst
possible
imaginable cop ever i'm michael knowles
is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from frosted ice
pharaoh
who says leftists and squishes use the
term
dog whistle yet they are the only ones
who can hear it what does that tell you
i have made this point on a number of
occasions i'm glad that you've picked up
on this too
the left is incessantly talking about
dog whistles and yet they are the only
ones to hear them what does that mean
that of course means
that they are the dogs and they are
because we don't hear them it's not as
though
conservatives are feigning ignorance and
saying no i have no idea what you're
talking about
we really have no idea what they're
talking about we don't hear these things
because the left is constantly changing
the definitions of words
to have all of these new connotations
that we simply are not aware of this is
part of their process
of constantly transforming the language
to try to transform
reality which is by the way the subject
of my upcoming book speechless
controlling words
controlling minds which is available now
by the way for
pre-order if you have pre-ordered
already i'm sure you can sleep easy at
night
one other great way to sleep easy my
pillow by now
how many times have you heard me talk
about my pillow a million times i've
told you it's the greatest
pillow in the world and how we all like
my pillows politics but even if it was a
communist country i would still support
my pillow now they have a new
product my slippers and they're just as
good that's the thing it's the politics
i kind of put that aside because of how
amazing
the product is these slippers took over
two years to develop they are designed
to wear indoors and outdoors all day
long
the my slippers are made with my pillow
foam and impact gel
to help prevent fatigue they're made
with quality leather suede
i can tell you firsthand these are
extraordinarily comfortable you are
going to love them the whole family is
going to want them
for a limited time my pillow is offering
40 off their new
my slippers 40 off 4-0
go check them out go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listeners square
and use the promo code daily wire you
will also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including
the giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper the my pillow towel sets
you can also call 800-951-7163
and use promo code daily wire go to
mypillow.com now or call 800-951-7163
this is the week this is the george
floyd trial week
when the whole nation for some reason is
focused on this one
criminal trial where a cop
used force on a guy
with a long rap sheet who was high on
drugs and resisting arrest
and there's a question did he use too
much for us did he not use too much
force
did he murder this guy did he commit
manslaughter dil
all in the weeds of what is essentially
a local a local crime
story that the left has turned into
a national reckoning on race
and they've contrived all sorts of
aspects of it and they have now
explicitly
threatened to riot and burn down the
country as they did last year
if they don't get the outcome that they
want in this trial
it's hard to see how the jury
does not convict here it's hard to see
not because of the evidence i think the
prosecution's done a pretty weak job
and i think the defense has done a
pretty good job and i think so many
facts
of this case were completely hidden or
distorted
in the political melee that took place
in 2020
however think about what's going to
happen if this jury doesn't convict
their their lives are going to be ruined
they're going to be targeted by
a murderous mob that has the explicit
support of elected officials
and many other people in the media their
families are going to be targeted
you're already seeing this sort of thing
happen there was a paramedic who donated
a little bit of money
to the defense of of kyle
what's his name kyle rittenhouse in
kenosha wisconsin
people are showing up to this guy's
house now this is just what happens when
you contradict the left's narrative on
this so
just for self-preservation i suspect
that the jury here is going to
convict the judge actually makes this
point himself this goes back to what
i've been saying from the beginning
i wish elected officials would stop
talking about this case
especially in a manner that is
disrespectful to the rule of law
and to the judicial branch in our
function
i think if they want to give their
opinions they should do so in a
respectful
and in a manner that is consistent with
their oath to the constitution
to respect the co-equal branch of
government
their failure to do so i think is
abhorrent but i don't think it is
prejudiced
with additional uh material that would
prejudice his jury they have been told
not to watch the news
i trust they are following those
instructions and that there is not
in any way a prejudice to the defendant
beyond the articles that we're talking
specifically about the facts of this
case
a congresswoman's opinion really doesn't
matter a whole lot anyway
so motion for mr house tonight okay so
he
denies the motion here for mistrial but
he says look on appeal
if let's say chauvin is convicted if
it's all thrown out on appeal
there really might be a strong case to
be made here but but in this trial
i trust that the jury is not watching
the news so look if the jury
is not watching the news at all they're
really they're not talking to anybody
about this trial
and they have i don't know general
amnesia
from 2020 then perhaps
then perhaps chauvin gets off
or he gets some lesser conviction but if
it's
if they're in any way talking to anybody
if they're
listening to the news if they can even
hear the screams and whales and threats
that are floating through the air
especially in minnesota right now then
it's very very
difficult to see how he gets off
blm already burned the country down it's
not as though this is some new news
story everyone knows about it
but i think frankly by the way the
left-wing establishment is probably
hoping that chauvin does get off because
if chauvin
is convicted then that's the end of the
story that's the end of it for the media
they won't get their ratings
that's the end of it for the radicals
they won't have an excuse
to riot in the street and and extort
more concessions out of the
establishment
now mowing the flat catchers to use the
phrase of tom wolf the writer
uh that will be the uh
end of it for the liberal establishment
itself which is constantly trying
to take more power so
what are they going to do i don't know
they're probably going to encourage the
riots maxine waters has gone viral
because of that clip
that that was going around yesterday
where she said we need to get
more aggressive we need to get more
confrontational more confrontational
than burning down multiple cities
what's more confrontational than that a
nuclear weapon but this is not
new for maxine waters maxine waters has
been doing this
for decades maxine waters did this
during the rodney king riots back in the
early nineties
as i stand here nine people
are dead my last count last this morning
before i tried to get some sleep
was over 50 something fires raging all
over los angeles
the fire started in my district and one
of the largest was right around the
corner from my house
there are scores of injuries and still
anger and frustration and people who
plan on staying on the streets and
expressing their
outrage and anger in any way they deem
necessary
there are those who would like for me
and others and all of us
to tell people to go inside to be
peaceful
that they have to accept the verdict i
accept the responsibility of asking
people not to endanger their lives i am
not asking people not to be angry
i am angry and i have a right to that
anger and the people out there have a
right to that anger
maxine waters does not have a right to
any anger she
she does not maxine waters does not
what maxine waters is doing is
provoking riots and what she says here
is look i'll
i accept the responsibility of telling
people not to go out and endanger their
own lives and i can be read in one of
two ways either
the writers who are saying don't go out
there and commit these crimes
and put yourself in a dangerous
situation or that could be
just the law-abiding citizens and the
shop owners saying hey look i'm telling
you don't go out don't
fight back don't endanger your own life
either way
not a great concession brutus i'm going
to accept that
but i'm not going to tell people not to
be angry i'm not going to tell people
not to express that anger
you should if you cared about your
country you would do that if you cared
about justice
you would do that now she's even lost
the
facade of trying to be reasonable now
she just says you get up on their face
and you
mob them and you get conf more
confrontational
after burning down the country for a
year so she she no longer has that
filter this happens to most people as
they get a little bit older
all of that to say i see the leftist
strategy
the leftist strategy is you
encourage the riot you encourage the
chaos and then as a result you get the
crackdown
and they like both of those things they
like the chaos because they can extort
concessions
on the left and then they like the
crackdown because that gives them
more power i just never want to hear
about a right-wing insurrection again i
never want to hear about it i don't want
to hear about
january 6th and capitol hill
and the greatest worst insurrection in
u.s history i don't want to hear about
it
as long as maxine waters faces zero
consequences which is exactly what's
going to happen
then i just don't want to hear about it
i don't there's these things are not
comparable
what blm and antifa did to the country
in 2020 what they're probably going to
do
in a week or two just not comparable to
the guy with the crazy horns jumping on
the on the table in the capitol
building okay by the way by the way what
were we told
about the capital what was the worst
thing that happened at the capitol riot
what was
basically the entire premise of the
second farcical impeachment of donald
trump the death of our
officer sicknick right that was the one
thing they said yeah okay
they messed up nancy pelosi's office
that's bad but we're not going to beat
you guy over that
and yeah the the guy in the horns jumped
on the table but we're not going to
impeach the president over that
but the thing we can get him on even
though trump said be peaceful the thing
we can get him on
is that officer brian sicknick capitol
hill police officer was killed
during those riots and and killed by
right-wing insurrectionists
and it turns out that story was just
completely false don't take my word for
it you don't even need to take the daily
wires word for it
the washington post is now finally
admitting that
what we all suspected the whole time it
was so weird that no one came out with a
cause of death
for officer sicknick officer sicnik
obviously died the question was did he
die because of the violence of that day
turns out nope no
completely unrelated even the wapo
headline capitol police officer brian
sicknick who engaged rioters suffered
two strokes
and died of natural causes officials say
thanks for admitting that wapo thanks
for admitting that
now that it doesn't matter now that
you've gotten every
single political advantage you can
possibly get out of that lie
now they admit the truth and they move
on nothing to see
here everybody just return to your homes
return to your bedrooms
when you get there have a nice nap in
your helix
mattress helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
for you why would you buy a mattress
made for someone else that doesn't make
any sense
you're a special person you need special
details in your mattress
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep it's fabulous
but you don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com
knowles take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they will match you to a customized
mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for
hundred nights risk free they will even
pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will love
it i really love my helix
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders right now and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com
knowles that is helix sleep dot com
slash knowles for up to 200
off and two free pillows the washington
post
admitting now months after
what we were four or more than three
months after the capital riot
february march april there we go three
months after the capital riot after
they've impeached the president a second
time failed to convict
after they've painted all of the right
as
insurrectionist threats to the country
need to clamp down on your speech
need to clamp down on your ability to
communicate
now they acknowledge the death of
capitol police officer brian siknik
didn't have anything to do with rioters
throwing fire hydrants at him didn't
have anything to do with any of that
his family had suggested to those paying
close attention
we we knew this was probably going to
come out because the family had
suggested at the time
that he had health problems don't rush
to judgment
they didn't want the death to be
politicized now it turns out
yeah it was two two strokes died of
natural
causes the following day very sad very
sad that the guy died apparently he
was he was not a radical leftist let's
put it that way
uh and then his death was totally
exploited by the radical left what was
the other
consequence of that it wasn't just
impeaching the president the other
consequence is we got to shut down
parlor
that's right remember when all those
squishes and leftists told conservatives
to build their own twitter
well then conservatives built their own
twitter and then and then the leftists
said no we're not going to allow that
and they kicked it off the app store and
they kicked it off the internet
and the squish is just rolled over like
they always do remember that
just to just to catch you up on what
happened well
some conservatives and some people with
spines
in the senate came out like people like
mike lee came out
and wrote to parlor and said hey you
guys can't do this representative ken
buck in the house wrote two parlor
and parlor or rather wrote to the apple
app store
apple finally wrote back to them and
said the app review team
has informed parlor as of april 14 2021
that its proposed updated app will be
approved
for reinstatement in the app store okay
great parlor is back
after they broke parlor after they
cracked that social platform
after they clamped down on them and said
you're the cause of the riot that killed
the police officer
now they're going to let them back in is
this a good thing or a bad thing
is this a win is what we want to know
well we need more information
before we can celebrate because
you see the fine print there they're
saying there's a new updated app and so
that's going to be proposed
for reinstatement in the app store so
what changes did parlor have to make
did parlor acquiesce or is this really
apple conceding to political pressure
all of that is sort of beside the point
i mean i guess it's good if parlor's
back in the app store that's fine but
it's sort of beside the point because
the liberal establishment already got
what it wanted
with that when it really counted january
6th
when it really counted what happened the
mainstream media
lied to you completely fabricated events
that day that did not happen
big technology clamped down they didn't
just censor the duly elected sitting
president of the united states
they also censored millions of
conservatives
who could now no longer use parlor as if
they were using it or sign up to use
parlor
that was done it was over they flexed
they showed we
run the show here we are the law
we are the system of justice so now
months later it's kind of all over it's
kind of a moot point yeah maybe they'll
let us back in a little bit on their
terms
but what's the real system here is this
really a win for for conservatives
in the justice system in the united
states i don't think so i think it's
probably the left
flexing their muscles and now out of
their beneficence giving us a little
some crumbs from the table how
how sweet of you left wingers
it's good to have wings on the cultural
level or at the business
corporate level we need wins at the
government level too so there's here's
half a good news story you want half a
good news story it's from arizona
governor doug ducey
who is now prohibiting the vaccine
passports at the government level
uh ducey is banning this new
proposal and he's preventing state and
local governments from requiring
residents to provide
the covid vaccine status to receive
service or to enter an area this is
at the government level but that doesn't
go far enough
it needs to go further we've we've
talked about this from the beginning
we've said they're going to be
two they're gonna be three different
positions here one is going to be
no vaccine passports at the government
level one is going to be no
vaccine passports at the government or
private business level
and then obviously the third the third
position is we need vaccine passports
wherever you know all over the place and
the libertarian position kind of is up
in the it's not really clear whether
which one the libertarians will go for
it's a little incoherent but
you could see a world which the
libertarian position is and the squish
position
is no no vaccine passports at the
government level
private businesses can do whatever they
want though if they want to include one
that's fine if they don't want to
include one that's also fine
the conservative position is no it's
just it upends our political order it
happens our traditions it opens our way
of life
no vaccine passports anywhere and then
obviously the leftist position they love
the passports
ron desantis then came out and he was he
did it a little bit slowly but then he
came out and he said okay florida we're
not going to have vaccine passports even
private businesses we're not gonna do it
we need more people to step up 27
republican governors here
i'm glad to see what four or five have
come out and said no vaccine passports
at the
at the state level that's fine we need
to go further
we need to go further don't let them
give you a half measure
private businesses should not be
permitted to
require these either florida's doing a
lot florida's really leading the country
in many ways on this sort of stuff not
just on covid but on the riots too
because you know
riots are the they're the real vaccine
riots are the real cure for covid that's
what we learned during the blm riots of
2020.
we all have to stay locked in if we even
so much just go outside we're going to
catch this
virus with 100 chance of killing us
except if you are burning down
minneapolis
then that is actually going to there's a
shield that's going to go around you
and nobody can get coved so it's cool
especially
if you want like a booster you have to
bust into a nike store and steal some
sneakers
that is that's kind of like your that's
like the second shot you get the
sneakers there's no way you can get
covered right
so we're all preparing for more riots
minneapolis totally boarded up other
places in the country are preparing
how's florida preparing they're
preparing by beefing up laws
and figuring out ways to throw rioters
in prison for longer
florida's senate has approved a bill
that was championed by
governor desantis it's an anti-riot law
it permits citizens to sue a local
government
if that government does not stop a riot
it defines a riot as a
violent public disturbance involving
three or more people acting with common
intent resulting in injury to others
damage to property or the imminent
danger of injury or
damage this law also would grant civil
legal immunity to people
who would drive through protesters and
rioters who are blocking a road
that's a good provision i like that
that's good that's good for law order
it's good for a stable society it's good
for everybody's rights
this law would prevent people who were
arrested for rioting or offenses
committed during a riot
from getting bailed out of jail until
their first court appearance loves that
love that a lot throw them in jail throw
away that key at least until their court
appearance
and this would impose a six-month
mandatory sentence for battery on a
police officer during a riot love that
love that but the left should love that
too right because they pretend that
they're all for law and order now
after the great horrible insurrection of
january 6th
right so love this law think it's
absolutely
phenomenal this is not a clampdown on
people's freedom
that's what the left is going to say
you're taking away our freedom of
expression and our freedom of speech
this is an expansion of freedom of
speech
because rioting is not speech that's not
protected by the first amendment
you have the right to speech you have
the right to peaceably assemble
you don't have the right to burn
buildings down you don't have the right
to threaten people you don't have right
a right to
shut down the interstate and if you do
that
you need to be punished so that we get
less of that so we dis-incentivize that
and so that we punish people who do very
bad things
you're going to hear people say this is
outrageous this is not in keeping with
the
american tradition the anglo-american
tradition so we're not even allowed to
use that phrase anymore
riot acts have a long history in our
political tradition
you ever hear the phrase oh man read
them the riot act oh yeah that guy
you know you know what they're going to
do to him they're going to read them the
riot act do you ever hear that
expression that expression refers to
the riot act an english law back in
1714 when parliament passed the riot act
for much the same reason that we need to
pass the riot act today down in florida
and hopefully elsewhere around the
country my
one real disappointment with the trump
administration
i felt this was just bad instincts or he
was being led by people who did not know
what they were doing
was when he really went all in on the
jailbreak bill and he said you know as
conservatives we need to let a bunch of
criminals out of jail
i thought president trump this is going
against your political instincts
this is not the sort of stuff you've
talked about in your career this this
ain't it chief
you've been so good on so much other
stuff but this ain't it
i am glad to see that governor desantis
is bringing us back a little bit in the
direction
of law and order i hope that other
governors
other legislators around the country do
that as well
because we are not going to get any sort
of
uh real pushback from the squishes on
capitol hill
you know we're we're waiting on maxine
waters who is calling
for riots who who is
doing so almost explicitly very very
implicitly but
maybe arguably explicitly she's not
gonna face consequences
maybe now some people in the house of
representatives are saying if she's
we're gonna
we're gonna do something we're gonna do
something ben will be covering
maxine today on raging waters what a
great title uh so go check out his show
today we've also got backstage coming up
tonight 7 p.m eastern 4 p.m pacific
and it's almost time for another episode
of candace this week's special guest is
dana white
president of the ultimate fighting
championship which is the largest mixed
martial arts
organization in the world the show
streams on fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central
only on dailywire.com you can get 25 off
a new membership
with code candace go check that out
today
we'll be right back with a lot more
so nancy pelosi was asked by the press
are you
going to hold maxine waters to account
do you you know you've just been
prattling on for three months about the
right-wing insurrectionists
now maxine waters is calling for an
insurrection or she's going for riots in
the streets to subvert for the explicit
purpose of subverting our justice system
so do you think she should apologize she
goes now not only do i not
think that we're going to hold maxine
waters to any consequence but i don't
think she should even apologize so
kevin mccarthy who at times has defended
the conservative side of the party
at other times has gone squish he
tweeted out quote maxine waters is
inciting violence in minneapolis
just as she has incited it in the past
if speaker pelosi doesn't act
against this dangerous rhetoric i will
bring action this week
so it this is doesn't really have any
meat to it because the best he can do is
suggest that maxine waters be censured
and then i guess you try to get her
impeached it's just none of that's going
to
happen but i guess it at least puts
democrats in a bad position
if they have to vote on whether or not
to censure her because they're not going
to want to vote to censure her but then
we'll be able to say that they all
defend the riots
so you know it's i i want to be a little
nice to mccarthy here because i was
tough on him yesterday
this actually has some cleverness to it
it will at least allow republicans to
hammer democrats and force the democrats
to own the riots that look like they're
about to ensue
however what this shows you is just
there's not not a lot
that you can do if in congress generally
but also if you're the party that's not
in power you got to win you got to win
elections
losing with dignity if that is actually
what republicans are doing and i don't
think that's what they're doing i think
they're losing without any dignity
but losing with even with dignity and a
buck 50 will get you a cup of coffee
if you don't have the political power
then you can't wield it and if you do
have the political power and you don't
wield it then
it's just as good as losing and now the
democrats have the political power and
they know how to wield it
and i just wish republicans could
republicans have convinced themselves
that it's somehow wrong to wield
political power
they've convinced themselves that the
only legitimate thing to do once they
enter office is nothing
because of some degraded
pseudo-libertarian bumper sticker
and they've convinced themselves that if
they create any laws that that's somehow
an illegitimate imposition
of our views and it it somehow
compromises freedom or something it's
just completely ridiculous
has no relationship to our actual
american conservative political
tradition
i talk about how the left is tricked us
into believing all this nonsense
in my upcoming with speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order and
by the way you can get an autograph
first edition copy if you go to premiere
collectibles just
just throwing that out there so kevin
mccarthy will try to
do this sort of thing pelosi won't act
probably very little will come of it
what about joe biden what about the
white house
does joe biden support the statements by
maxine waters
jensaki was asked this question because
obviously the press never talked to joe
biden
so the press secretary was asked this
she just doesn't give a straight answer
you talk to all the white houses
preparing for whatever that verdict is
congresswoman maxine waters said over
the weekend that they need to
we've got to stay on the street we've
got to get more active
we've got to get more confrontational
we've got to make sure that they know
that we mean business
does the president agree with what she
said about getting more
confrontational well i can speak to the
president's view
he has been very clear that he
recognizes the issue of police violence
against
people of color communities of color is
one of great english
and it's uh exhausting and quite
emotional
at times as you know he met with the
floyd family last year and has been
closely following the trial as we've
been talking about
and is committed to undoing this
long-standing systemic problem
his view is also that exercising first
amendment rights and protesting and
justice is the most
american thing that anyone can do but as
he also always says
protests must be peaceful that's what he
continues to call for and what he
continues to believe
is the right way to approach uh
responding
cool can you just give a straight answer
please lady i know i know you can i know
the job is not to give a straight answer
so i'm not
i'm not i'm not really personally angry
at jensaki here but
i guess this is an extreme example so
so joe biden doesn't want to contradict
a member of his own party
and he does in a way want to for his
political advantage wants to keep the
threat of riots out there because it it
well just like any threat of violence
right it it puts your
your opponent in a vulnerable position
it's like the mob it's like a nice story
you got here sure would be a shame if
something happened to it that's what
maxine waters is doing that's what the
whole democratic establishment is doing
it's not just crazy magazine kamala
harris bailed the rioters out of prison
last year out of jail rather
in in minneapolis the first time they
did this but joe biden's staffers
posted the the fundraiser for these
rioters as well
a lot of left-wingers are doing this
sort of thing then kamalaris came out
and said you got to stay in the streets
you did the same thing maxine waters is
doing
but joe biden doesn't want to be seen as
defending the riot so he says well
you know we believe you got to be
peaceful but you know we also believe
and will
and but and well and but and if ifs and
butts were candy and nuts we'd all have
a merry christmas
what is the end game here i
i don't think the end game is simply
that the left wants
us all to devolve into some anarchistic
mayhem in the country they want to upend
the culture for a purpose
and that is to impose their own
vision their own standards and so that
the chaos really helps them because then
the clampdown can be even tougher
and you're seeing ultimately what this
clampdown is going to be is not from
the ordinary part of the american
political tradition where you know the
democrats win elections then they follow
the normal process no
what it's going to be is perpetually
outsourcing
their our political rights to the
administrative bureaucracy which is
always in their hands even even when we
do win elections
the bureaucracy is always in their hands
and they're going to take political
questions and they're going to try to
redefine them as non-political questions
and they're going to take questions of
our fundamental constitutional rights
and they're going to redefine them as
scientific
clinical administrative questions that
eggheads like dr
fauci should decide rather than we the
people of the united states
fouchy's already doing this he was asked
a question about gun
policy why is dr fauci being asked about
gun policy
i have no idea actually i do have an
idea because we now have a
state church in this country called
secular progressivism and dr
fauci is the high pontiff of secular
progressivism so all questions go to him
he speaks infallibly
on absolutely all matters and because
the left
redefines all of our language
as a strategy to redefine reality
they're trying to redefine the question
of our second amendment rights
as a matter of public health
before i let you go i want to ask about
another epidemic in the u.s and that is
gun violence
eight people were shot and killed in a
mass shooting in indianapolis on
thursday night the u.s
has reported 47 mass shootings in just
over a month you've worked in public
health broadly
for a long time is gun violence in the
u.s a public health emergency
you know myself as as a public health
person i
i think you can't run away from that i
mean when you see people
getting killed i mean in this last month
it's just been horrifying
what's happened how can you say that's
not a public health issue
i can say it's not a public health issue
how can how can you say it is a public
health issue first of all i've been told
that people
who are killed by bullets are actually
being killed by kovit remember
people who get shot in the head in some
cases in this country have been counted
as covid deaths
we've been told that all all deaths are
part of the public health issue
so all people die right all all people
die
and therefore everything in this world
is a public health question
because look if i this show right now
this is a public health matter
because if i say something that really
irritates
a leftist which i've been told i
occasionally do well then their blood
pressure might rise up a little bit they
may they'll have a health problem from
that maybe you know don't think that i'm
making
a totally hyperbolic ridiculous straw
man argument the left makes this point
all the time they make the point on
racism
they say that racism is a public health
issue because when people suffer
microaggressions that raises their blood
pressure and that
that's difficult for them and it's a
matter of life and death sometimes
and therefore the eggheads need to take
over
all of our national policy if you're if
you're looking at mass shootings in the
country
you're saying yeah a lot of criminals
are going out and shooting people
if you're going to interview an expert
on that some
some official of the government
shouldn't you be interviewing i don't
know
a member from the department of justice
a prosecutor
a cop the attorney general
why are you interviewing dr fauci
because public health
is this catch-all department of the
government
it's going to become the whole
government now that makes all of our
national policy no
official in the government has had more
power than dr fauci
over the past two years including
donald trump including joe biden
dr fauci almost single-handedly has up
ended our entire way of life
suspended our our ordinary
rituals suspended christmas suspended
thanksgiving
got our election system upended to
include now massive widespread mail-in
votes
to expand election day well beyond
election day
that was fouchy that was public health
because everything falls in
to the cult of public health and and we
are told by the way we're not we're not
allowed to question this
because that makes us unscientific look
that's just the way science
is progressing and there's a science to
our bodies and there's a science to
history
and there's a science to politics and
that's just progress man and you're on
the wrong side of history and you got to
just shut up
and give up your country to these
deranged eggheads right
or not there was a video this is going
to seem unconnected but it's not
there was a video that was going around
the internet over the past few days
of a cool old plane making an emergency
landing in the water along a beach
in florida so so the plane
is making its landing and
and it so it's really actually pretty
impressive emergency landing
doesn't doesn't take anybody out and you
see the the plane just floating now a
little bit off
shore some guys are filming this from
the beach
and already you think wow this is very
impressive video but the most impressive
part comes
when a bunch of dudes start running into
the water
diving into the water and swimming out
to the plane
why are they doing that because they
want to make sure that nobody in the
plane needs help
that nobody's drowning that nobody has
maybe been knocked unconscious
they're running toward the danger using
their will and their intellect
to do the right thing taking the
situation
in some degree into their own hands and
behaving in a moral manner as they do it
we can do that i know that we we live in
a country now
that is just filled with the neurotic
and selfish fear of death
where if forget about a plane landing
and you're gonna you're gonna go run
toward the danger
now if your grandma coughs
you run in the other direction you say
good death take her take her i've gotta
i gotta get out of here i'm not gonna
see
my relatives my loved ones for years at
a time now
because i'm so afraid of getting the
sniffles
right we are a cowardly and selfish
country in many ways
we're quickly becoming that because of
radicals who are trying to upend our our
system of
society but we don't have to be we can
be the other kind of society
that just doesn't care about our
our own self of satisfaction all the
time
that doesn't only care about our
self-preservation it actually runs
toward the danger
to do the right thing we can take back
control because i think the theme
the theme of this white house is losing
control
kamala harris was just sent out to meet
the the prime minister of japan
yoshihide suga
now normally this this is an important
relationship
normally the president would go out to
meet the prime minister of japan but joe
biden was probably taking his nap
probably the prime minister's arrival
didn't didn't work out very well for him
and so they sent kamala harris instead
and it just looked it looked awkward it
was it was disrespectful it's not the
right sort of thing
joe biden the other day accidentally had
to give an answer to a reporter who
caught him while he was walking
and he said behind the mask he was asked
about the border crisis and he said
right he said you couldn't hear him that
well because he muzzled himself which is
probably to his political advantage but
he called it
a crisis first time that biden has
has called it a crisis the white house
assiduously avoiding these sorts of
terms jen saki was just asked about this
said hold on
joe biden says it's a crisis so can the
white house finally admit it's a crisis
she says
no president biden over the weekend
called what happened at the border
of crisis is that now the official white
house position that there is indeed a
crisis at the border
well let me first say um that we have
made
some progress some progress in moving
children from uh out of border patrol
facilities
into shelters nearly a thousand
unaccompanied
minors were transferred out of cbp
facilities and into the care of health
and human services
just this weekend we are still have a
lot of work to do but we
that is a step forward in our view the
president does not feel
that children coming to our border
seeking refuge from violence economic
hardships and other
dire circumstances is a crisis he does
feel
that the crisis in central america the
dire circumstances
that many are fleeing from that he that
that is a situation we need to spend our
time our effort on and we need to
address it if we're going to prevent
more of an influx of migrants from
coming in years to come
that's not what he said he said the
crisis is at the border and what gensake
is saying now
is no what the president said that's not
the position of the white house
that's not the position of the white
house
i it probably isn't because i don't
think joe biden really runs that white
house
we are not merely the
victims the passive victims of
circumstance
we are not merely the
the sort of cogs in the machine that
have no will and have no intellect of
our own we do have agency we have
intellect we have
will we can do things we can we can take
even terrible events
and try to find some way to pull some
good
out of those events the left doesn't
want us to be able to do that the left
wants to keep us
ginned up and wild all the time and
and really focused on all all the most
awful aspects of our
of our country and of our lives and told
we can never do anything
we can never succeed and we can never
overcome
and they're they're our only hope and
keep us all agitated
the left often exploiting political
crises and deaths we've got officer
siknik right here from the washington
post
exploiting those things to push their
own radical agenda disconnected from the
question at hand
i am reminded that today is the
anniversary of the columbine shooting 22
years
a lot of people probably listening to
the show don't even remember the
columbine shooting well i sat down
with one of the survivors of the
columbine shooting craig scott
we discussed a whole range of times a
really long interview you can go check
it out on my youtube channel
he focused specifically though on the
way the media politicize
these sorts of events and push lies to
fit their
agenda he also gives a really harrowing
recount of what he
saw himself what he went through himself
on that day
just play you a little clip of of our
discussion and then you can go
check out the rest of it on my youtube
channel you can also check out the movie
about
his sister called i am not ashamed
without further ado take a listen
there's definitely uh things that are
taken tragedies
events that the media picks up on that
they want to politicize
it uh they want to use it for whatever
cause that they think
um is important or needs or or needs to
happen
and uh you know i've been involved and
interviewed and
questioned um over news media i've been
over on a thousand
interviews throughout my life and that
that's a
issue that comes up a lot but i i know
that that
is a surface level issue
i know that um that when somebody has
um real darkness real hatred in their
heart
uh that if they want to take the time to
plan and kill people they can find a way
to do it
there was actually a propane tank that
was set at columbine
that was right underneath me i was on
the second floor in the library
directly below me in the cafeteria was a
propane tank if it had gone off it would
have killed
500 kids and we would have been you know
banning propane tanks
you know people that that use these
events for their own
uh agenda i think that a lot of them
really believe that that this is the
problem you know they think that the gun
the guns are the problem
but it really wasn't the main problem uh
if you really want to look at i i
know of every school shooting that's
happened since columbine
i get questioned by the media after
everyone i research it i learn about it
and if i were to tell you the biggest
thing the biggest commonality between
all these school shooters
it's pretty simple it's that they focus
on
everything that was negative in this
world
they focused on everything that was
negative in themselves and they didn't
see the good
in themselves or in other people and
they had this
perspective of seeing the world they
could have been in the most beautiful
place they could have been in the
sistine chapel in
in italy with michelangelo's beautiful
paintings and found
dirt in the corner and focused on that
and
when you have a view where everything is
dark and jaded
and you see nothing good then in you it
creates
a darkness it creates an anger and a
hatred and what i've learned
also about all these shooters school
shootings is that
they all dwelled on a lot of very
negative media
almost on a daily basis and if you can
just imagine
um and you know of course there's
there's there's there's nothing negative
in the media right
when i ask that question to students in
schools i say
you know how many of you guys would
agree there's a lot of negative like in
the media like every hand goes up
negative media is sort of a redundant
phrase
you don't need to say both right you
know uh
it doesn't mean you can't address the
negative or talk about it but where is
your focus
because whatever we place attention on
we give power to
whatever it is whatever the media
chooses to focus on
the media told this narrative after
columbine that really wasn't true
and columbine was such a covered
thing after the shooting it was on the
news for months and we had
a news camp of reporters near the school
for months
and the narrative that basically came
out was this
two guys are pushed to the edge because
of bullying
and they get revenge at their school the
problem is that's really not the true
story
that's really not the main issue and
even the psychologists that have looked
into it
that have looked at everything that
happened don't believe bullying was a
factor they were bullied to a degree at
school i know of a couple stories
i also know kids at my school that were
bullied a lot worse and i also know that
they themselves were bullies
at times and became the ultimate bullies
that day
if i were to tell when i talk to kids i
say the biggest reason they did what
they did
is that they focused on everything that
was negative in this world
and that's that's the bigger reason it's
not bullying
um the bigger reason is is what they
focused on
and so i have a program called value up
and i
named it that after reading um the book
from sue kliebold her son was dylan one
of the shooters at columbine
dylan wasn't going to go through with
the shooting he thought eric his friend
who was very
psychopathic um was crazy and he only
decided to go
along with it in the last couple months
of his planning he planned it for a year
and but he was more suicidal and what
his mom said was we
valued dylan but he didn't value himself
and it struck me because i realized i
had already spoken to over a million
teens across
the country in person and i realized
that's such a core issue
when somebody doesn't believe in their
own value
they're not going to treat other people
with value but if they can realize the
truth and whether you want to come out
this from a
christian perspective or other religion
that you know christians you're
fearfully wonderfully made
other perspective that we just have the
capacity within us to do great good
we have so much potential especially
young people
and so if they can realize it doesn't
matter what they look like
it doesn't matter what other people say
about them it doesn't matter where they
come from
who their family is that they have a
great potential
in them to and and the capacity to do
great things
and be a positive influence in this
world like my sister was
she did small things stepped out of her
way for
a a girl that sat all alone during lunch
who just lost her mom in a car accident
a friend a friend told me how he has a
slight disability he was made fun of and
ignored usually ignored a lot at school
his name was
adam and the first time she met him she
stood up
a couple guys were making fun of him she
stood up for him
and he told me that the time that she
reached out to him he was having
thoughts of taking his life
and after she met him every day in the
hallway she would just say hi to him
and he said he literally started waking
up in the morning
looking forward to this day that this
pretty girl would say hi to him in the
hallway
in a small act of kindness human
connection
what is going to really change our
culture what's real
how are we going to get to the root of
the problem well the root of the problem
is in our hearts the root of the problem
is it really is those are where the
problems are it's also where the
solutions are
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show as
the chauvin jury begins its
deliberations the media ratchet up the
racial tension
and maxine waters pushes violence in the
streets as democrats and the media
defend her that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen